voilà un message posté il ya quelques
heures à peine par la star de télé
réalité loana qui n'a pas fini de faire
le buzz
la jeune femme a publié cet après-midi
des photos chocs de l'ensemble de son
corps couvert d'hématomes des images
extrêmement choquant
accompagné d'un message expliquant qu'il
aurait été roué de coups par son ex
compagnon durant des heures j'étais
aphone à force d'avoir hurler arrête de
me frapper durant quatre heures il m'a
frappé et hurler dessus sans s'arrêter
une minute un enfer que j'avais jamais
vécu d'une telle violence sur autant de
temps j'aurais préféré mourir je me
cachais dans toutes les pièces les coins
en priant qu'il s'arrête je lui disais
même oui lorsqu'il me disait que j'étais
qu'une kaunas pour qu'ils soient
contents elle accuse nommément fred
couvin qui serait selon elle l'auteur de
ces violences lohan ajoute qu'il aurait
été manipulée par cet homme qu'elle
qualifie de pervers narcissique alors
loana que s'est il passé
alors est ce que vous avez pu avoir des
nouvelles de loana gilles vernets oui
alors bon c'est terrible pour elle c'est
au long de sa vie il ya de nombreuses et
la scène de d'ultra violence conjugale
et notamment le 8 février avec alors on
va garder le conditionnel avec
semble-t-il ce même homme
les policiers sont intervenus il était
entré une première fois il est ressorti
les entrées par effraction
il ya eu des scènes très violente elle a
été victime au début elle n'a pas voulu
porter plainte et puis finalement les
autorités judiciaires se sont saisis de
la faire il ya eu une mesure
d'éloignement qui l'a un peu protégés et
puis ça a repris ses c'est tragique pour
être cédés relation de couple c'est
compliqué je dirais que c'est une
relation très toxique pour elle très
violente et très dommageable c'est
vraiment terrible terrible
alors bien sûr c'est vrai que tous ceux
qui ont vu ces photos on a vu les
réactions dans le public on était très
très très choquée oui géraldine alors
oui évidemment on est choqué mais les
réseaux sociaux il faut pas oublier que
c'est pas la loi
en fait c'est l'émotion c'est le
sensationnalisme et moi voilà ce que je
peux te dire à loana c'est d'aller
porter plainte à nouveau bien sûr qu'à
que comme ça que ça peut ça peut avancer
et c'est comme ça que la justice peut
s'améliorer et faire des peines de plus
en plus dur de plus en plus exemplaires
alors voilà c'est le choc des images le
poids des mots c'est incontestable il ya
quand même une présomption d'innocence
même si on a du mal à l'imaginer mais
malgré tout encore une fois on l'a
beaucoup par ici avec manon ce temps
port il faut toujours aller porter
plainte
c'est la base mais là le problème de
l'eau amassée que c'est quelqu'un dit
sensible et le problème c'est qu'elle a
cherché le soutien de ses fans parce
qu'elle sait qu'elle est très mal
entouré ça fait trois quatre ans que je
parle avec elle et là j'ai perdu le fil
parce que j'ai perdu mon portable cet
été je n'ai pu son numéro mais c'est
quelqu'un de vraiment hyper sensible et
elle a juste chercher le soutien des
gens qu'il aime
selon elle malheureusement mais des gens
qui la suivent sur instagram pour
pouvoir leur montrer
c'était un appel au secours c'est
vraiment quelqu'un d'extrêmement gentil
et moi ça me fait trop de peine de mort
est ce que c'est la télé qui a détruit
loi c'est la question qu'on se pose en
2001 le remporte la 1ère édition du loft
c'est la tequila détruire je pense que
évidemment c'est une personne qui était
déjà très très fragile voilà elle fait
montre à chaque fois d'une immense
fragilité et elle a été broyé par la
télé réalité
moi je forcément je pense à son parcours
elle était maman j'étais maman avant de
faire de la télé ralité aussi ferme
avant de faire la star academy le fait
d'être d'un coup comme ça très connu
situé très fragile ça peut te détruire
et elle en fait j'ai l'impression qu'à
chaque fois qu'elle parle à chaque fois
qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est un
immense cri de détresse d'un sos
il faut aider loana et je pense que les
réseaux sociaux sont un vrai danger pour
elle bien sûr nous avons voulu réagir au
delà de loana il en existe plein des
renards malheureusement il ya des
milliers et jardinent a dit encore porté
plainte moi c'est ça qui m'énerve avec
un gouvernement j'aimerais bien qu'on
crée une loi où on fait peur aux mecs à
tous et lâche qui veulent pas sortir
quand ils se font insulter par des mecs
en bagnole ça sort pas ça fait le canard
à 10h10 et ça va taper les ça va taper
leurs femmes parce que loana c'est bien
ce qu'elle a montré malheureusement elle
a montré mais faut aussi dire à des
femmes parce que tu dis courageuse
sensibilité mais il ya des femmes très
forte très courageuse qui sont happés
par leur mari mais qui ne peuvent rien
faire parce que les enfants derrière et
on peut pas sortir on peut pas quitter
le foyer comme ça parce qu'il ya des
enfants d'air moi j'aimerais bien ce
gouvernement c'est bien de se pencher
sur les rappeurs c'est extraordinaire
c'est bien de se pencher sur les
footballeurs qui ont un mauvais
comportement
mais le vrai combat de tous ces
féministes là qu'on voit twitté toutes
les deux minutes au gouvernement elle
est vrai combat il est là parce que les
femmes elles se sont tabassés et a dit
je bouge pas toutes façons les flics
vont venir
ils vont repartir dans leur voiture de
police avec la kangoo et le gyrophare
quand ils vont partir il va fermer la
porte et qui sera en face de moi le mec
il va m'en remettre une gm va me
remettre une encore plus fort donc moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on crée une loi pour
faire peur à ces mecs là pour que dise
voilà quand tu tapes une femme derrière
peut-être que tu vas rester de trois
jours en garde à vue peut-être 48 heures
on va te faire mouliner il attire
moulinet parce que ça c'est pas normal
et la rue
la ville
il a il a entièrement tape une femme il
est vrai que par des femmes sont
terrifiés et que souvent avec une barre
il a fini avec ses démons le problème tu
as raison mais évidemment que tu as
raison justement on a créé la fondation
des femmes qui s'occupent de ces femmes
battues s'est contre toutes les
violences faites aux femmes et il ya
plusieurs maisons comme ça en france qui
se développe pour ça que je dis il faut
soutenir la fondation des femmes c'est
la justice et que ce normal il assiste à
des fondations rené est ce que c'est la
télé qui l'a tué loana à qui le tour
parce que comme dit je pas qui est elie
wi fi et les faibles des d'entrer chez
les faibles la télé est de bois c'est ça
et quand elle tombe sur une connard
commence à moins qu' il a réservé à
bompas robinet rafeo formations para
mais je n'ai jamais parlé de la bm à
laquelle je pensais que la lotte voilà
comment s'appelle ce qui vaut au quilit
à la ministre des sports elle nous fait
chier promo quant à lui un stade mais
l'a rappelé me les a dépassés pour moi
les mecs commencent à jeter et chaud
près et il te couperai quiz la fia mais
tous n'ont pas découpées ouais ouais
mais attendez faire juste on s'aimerait
gc ca la justice de nantes sont pas très
bons gars semblent mettre garde à quoi
elle ressemble c'est pas vraiment ses
doublures sont ce que saab si les choix
personnels
loana est plusieurs fois qu'il l'a tapée
elle revenait toujours amoureuse de lui
après ses mots de m